so I want you to come back to remember
these four equations okay we're looking
at we'd be looking rather at simple
harbor aggression and we develop these
equations to say okay harmonic motion is
about when you've got this oscillating
kind of ideas things occur up there
predictably or left to right or whatever
it is and what makes is simple is a
simple a single rather true crunching
party beneath the ocean okay so it's
very very predictable you basically need
to know your amplitude frequency your
face if you like you can change the
center of motion that's it you know
everything about it the most recently we
saw was even though we say there's a
single trig function behind it what was
the most recently we looked at theater
last week do you remember yeah very good
we can express it if it's convenient to
us good boy even though there's only one
trig function reality if it's convenient
to us we can express it as like you know
some cos squared or sine squared a thing
like that or even is the sub of a sine
and cosine why don't we do that by that
was the most recent example we looked at
why would we express it as two trig
functions the summer to God than one has
OEM an Italian okay yeah very good when
you try to find the phase right good
morning this face here this alpha
sometimes you have to appeal to some
sort of messy trig functions and you
don't really won't have to do that so if
you can sort of craft things if you do
auxiliary angle in reverse and say I
don't want to have an alpha I just want
to have an empty and therefore I account
for that by the bloody having to ship
functions sometimes that's all a la vida
okay that's the most recent thing we
looked at so where I want to take us
from here is another implication of
these expressions right one of the first
things we encountered when we're meeting
simple harmonic motion is the ancient
days good Mike
each of these leads us if you recall to
a velocity function and acceleration
function but the acceleration function
for simple harmonic motion in both cases
was really nice add me does anyone
remember what it is for the first basic
case when you've got motion about the
origin it's minus and squared and so if
you differentiate twice if you
differentiate twice what happens is each
time you differentiate because of the
chain rule right you get an extra factor
of n remember that right side will try
to co-sign the first differentiation to
get to velocity the second
differentiation to get acceleration the
curse i will turn into negative sign
right so sorry ok so sine cosine there
you sign your bakit ex but there's a
minus sign along for the ride right and
do you remember your body what does that
negative in hey what's what's that
therefore yeah ok so whichever side of
the origin you are about right you're
accelerating in the opposite direction
right so if you're the positive side
you're going to accelerate in the
negative ratio which is what sends you
back to the center and if you're on the
negative side you're accelerating back
toward the positive side which again
sends you back to the center which is
not making simple equation in the same
way when we did it for this because what
you've got here once you do the first
differentiation good morning as soon as
you've done that this B disappears right
so therefore what difference do we get
here it's still mix- in sweat yes yeah
very good because what you get is down
the bottom um first derivative with me a
cause NT plus alpha the second area it
will be negative a side and T plus alpha
which is everything except with a babe
yes yeah do we are sides right to tell
look right
yeah be a minus you ok so the important
thing I want to do that for both of
these right isn't there differential
equations and then take us away like
both of these expressions here they take
us away from our reliance on time ok you
can know what your acceleration is
without knowing when you are all you
need to know is where you are ok so this
important idea which we've met through
simple humble Russian it should ring
some bells because we looked at this on
a natural growth in the cave to remember
this you can say for you don't need to
write this part for some population we
actually began for natural growth
indicated by say the definition is your
proportional to your population and then
we set our exponential functions they
satisfy the differential equation ok so
in other words you can express rates of
change right or acceleration etc without
knowing when you just need to know what
you're actually equal to or in this case
where you are ok so in our context for
motion that's the little domain we're at
the moment we're going to call this
motion as functions of rather than
functions of time right which is when
you are these are functions of
displacement where you are right
functions of displacement so we can
express velocity acceleration rather
than Tommy when we get expression
there's Tommy to me where ok and this by
the way and this is leaning towards into
mechanics rather than kid Maddox but
even as to attention what students you
can understand why this happens remember
i showed you the rubber band right and
the rubber band even if you don't worry
about what we go do it even if you don't
worry about the exactly reflects string
tension and directional I kind of think
it sort of makes sense that the further
away you are where you are dictates the
kind of acceleration that's after you
write or if you want to think about say
at object that's orbiting around a star
where you are in relation to this either
closer you are the more acceleration
your
towards the star does that make sense so
where is a natural way to think about
things in a lot of physical situations